all right just if everyone hear me all
right how's everyone doing this morning
no good all right I'm gonna go to get
started I am James Snell I am head of
research at near forum also a node core
contributor working on quite a bit of
things within node right now the thing
I'm working on is the quick
implementation that Rebecca was talking
about yesterday but in your form one of
the things that we do is you know we
have a lot of customers that come to us
and ask us but you know say hey our
stuff is slow
come help us figure out why our code is
slow and over the past couple of years
we've we've come to ask one very
specific question when a customer comes
to us and says hey our stuff is slow the
first question is are you using promises
alright and if they'd say yes our
response right away is you're using them
wrong well you know you haven't even
looked at our code yet there are not -
you're using them wrong all right so
what we have found in the overwhelming
majority of cases when anybody is using
promises they are it's some way it's
some level using them incorrectly so
that it's the inspiration of this talk
is basically all the ways that we have
seen customers using promises
incorrectly and kind of breaking down
why why it's incorrect kind of you know
how to how to avoid those issues now one
example they got caught up with a
customer they are having some really
poor response times on their API I
decided to do a 30 second benchmark on
one path of their code right so we're
basically just sending the same request
over and over and over again against
their server executing a single branch a
single path within that 30 second
benchmark they were allocating 30,000
Provinces okay I'll explain why in just
a little bit but there are a few other
examples like that that I will share
with you all right
so promises are powerful yes they're
there in a language you really have to
understand how how they function and
what their what their purpose is right
when to use them and especially when not
to use
all right everything that I'm going to
show you is based on what we have seen
actual customers do in production code
alright so you know some of the examples
you know I've I've simplified the
examples I'm not going to say what you
know who's you know what customers and
what companies are doing what right so
I've completely anonymized it some of
the examples may look a bit contrived
but they are based on stuff we've
actually seen in the out of the real
world
but first I want to do a puzzle I've
notice a few times this code prints a
message it's a secret message all right
without writing the code try to figure
out what the message is you could you
know without trying to copy down here
you can scan the QR code I'll also post
this on my Twitter feed after this but
you know the task is try to figure out
what the message is without running all
right what this code is doing is using
all the various ways you can schedule a
synchronous activity and note so we have
next tics we have immediate we have some
promises in there cue micro tasks right
so this will print a message out if you
figure it out again without running the
code let me know all right so I'll give
you a moment to folks it's against your
code okay all right so the reason I like
to start with this particular example is
it because it emphasizes the fact that
you really need to understand when code
is being executed within within a note
or then javascript in general all right
so we all know node is a JavaScript
platform right is JavaScript running all
of the time in node all right no all
right so let me show you a quick example
of this so if I do a set interval all
right I'm going to set it for you know
about a second actually let me let me
change this a little bit we're gonna set
it to run every 500 milliseconds and
we're gonna have this thing do a for
loop and then do a console.log very very
simple application so I'm gonna run this
I'm gonna turn on trace events
and we're gonna turn v8 nice and cooks
this is basically give us some insight
into what is happening under the covers
on this and they're gonna run this okay
so it's just gonna iterate through five
times that's going to end up creating
this file this node trace dot one file
let's pop back over chrome tracing is
it's a utility built into Chrome browser
allows you to be a trace amount log data
generated by node or by the browser so
let's load this thing up this file that
we just created this node underscore
trace might be a little bit hard to read
there from the back but these pink boxes
right here are the plate they're the
times when node and v8 or actually
executing JavaScript the blank spaces
between our times when no JavaScript is
being run that is times when the node
event loop is doing other things in this
case it's waiting for that event for
that timer to fire right so within that
time the event loop is actually spinning
right but while the pink boxes are
executing the event loop is not spinning
the event loop is completely blocked
okay now when we say schedule a
synchronous activity what we're talking
about is in one of the pink boxes
triggering some action that is not going
to complete until another pink box
starts okay you know on this so
basically like if we want to do a file
read write file read to note happen in a
in a thread pool so we trigger the file
read it's going to go off and read the
file in a separate thread when that file
then data is available after the event
loop turns right it'll see okay that
data is available now then it'll start
executing JavaScript again all right
with a promise you never ever want to
create a promise that resolves within
the same execution block that it was
created if you can avoid it all right
and I say you've waited for usually I
promise that resolved right that is
explicitly a synchronous promise right
with promises that you you know don't
ever use them where they resolve in the
same
you want to use it to you know when you
create it you're scheduling some
asynchronous activity it's happening off
the main event loop and then it's gonna
come back and execute later on right
that's key that's no that's that's
number one and I'll get into a little
bit about why that is a little bit later
okay so people do weird things with
async functions and promises they pass
them to functions that don't expect them
so creating an immediate timer with an
async function or setting a recurring
timer than async function what happens
in this case if this throws right what
happens is that I dare say he give you a
support email that's so that's basically
what you do what ends up happening in
this case is is this error catchable in
any way no you mean you can do a
try-catch inside this thing but then you
know your error happening is limited in
inside that you can't bubble it out
anywhere right
so with this case what you end up with
is an unhandled rejection you can't
actually catch any errors thrown within
that async function outside of that of
that function right we see this in all
kinds of places so if we take a look at
event you matter people love passing
async functions to you know to handle
events now just recently with in node
coral I'll show an example of this later
we just had a new feature landed called
capture rejections that makes event
emitter aware of promises but most cases
if you're talking about event you meter
if you're talking about callback
functions these things are not expecting
promises they're not expecting async
functions and they do not know how to
handle them correctly and what you're
going to end up with our cases where you
are either you know you know at the best
case you have an unhandled rejection at
the worst case you have memory leaks
resource leaks in this case we
would be leaking a file descriptor all
right that would never end up getting
closed if there's an error somewhere in
here you end up with a synchronous
context it's not propagated properly
down through all of your callbacks or
all your promises all right you can end
up with orphans promise chains they have
you have no way of handling all right
and all kinds of other kind of nastiness
you know and we actually get a de base
with this you know you know you know
Mateo clean has gotten on Twitter and
said don't mix callbacks and promises
together and then we actually end up
with debates on this on this stuff's
like no it's no problem
we can show specific examples here of
them of memory leaks happening right me
I have one in here I mean look at this
okay so right here we open a file and
it's just kind of the local file we read
it we open the file descriptor but you
know you have some error handling in
there right then let's call you know a
function you know you know happen to be
something that you know the reference is
not resolved right in this case that
async function is going to throw with an
unhandled rejection and that FS close is
never going to fire now a lot of times
we'll have a you know promise or a
process on on handled rejection to do
some logging all right so maybe your
your you know you'll see a nun held
rejection or an error in your logs but
the actual file descriptor itself never
actually gets close we see this all of
the time now it's possible to get around
this you use you know a try-catch in
this function use a finally in here to
close it but most of the time developers
completely forget to do that right this
is one of the most common issues that we
see all right so this is you know and
these are things that are that are that
are easily checked the simple rule on
this don't pass an async function or
promise to a callback that does not
expect it period just don't do it all
right now another weird one that we've
been seeing lately that's just bizarre
are people mixing new promise and async
functions right
the oddest one of this that I've seen
recently was a weight new promise that
was passed an async function and then to
resolve it was resolved await something
right I I still don't quite know what
they were trying to accomplish right it
was not what they expected all right let
me ask you this if I have a regular
function like this a new promise and I
throw in here right what's gonna happen
is that gonna get caught or is going to
be a thrown immediately
it's immediately thrown a lot of folks
say anything that's any error that
somewhat thinner promise is gonna get
caught by the catch handler
it is not right it's only caught if it
happens in a you know dot then or a dot
catch right you know in one of the in
the chain the function that is passed to
the promise itself that will throw
immediately when is this function
executed immediately right there is a
common misconception particularly among
developers that are coming from Java
and.net environments that new promise is
equivalent to new thread right there's
you know it's it's a very common
misconception I I I had to sit down and
prove it for I think it was about 45
minutes go through a proof for a
customer that we were at but there with
a helper team they were absolutely
convinced that new promise was was
running in parallel right just kind of
magical new threats there's a huge
amount of misconception out there about
how this works right so this error it's
gonna get thrown immediately what
happens if I do this okay pass the async
function that and we throw that error
all right again where we're going to end
up with
there's an unhandled rejection all right
now do you think the catch handler is
going to catch it let's just say let's
just console.log it right console.log
the message right you think that's gonna
handle it there's a they're coming you
know believed it yeah if you pass me a
promise to this thing you're worth in a
promises it will not catch it you got a
nun that'll projection the cash handler
cannot see this in any way but we are
seeing this more and more and more I
think we've seen this and I think three
or four customer projects just over the
past couple of months all right
and this is based on a belief that hey
async functions are great let's use them
everywhere no like just just no at all
all right so we have that one very
important just you know you have to be
very careful about where promises are
actually being used you they are a very
specific tool that are used only for
scheduling a synchronous activity and
waiting for the result of that activity
right but as we'll see as we go along
there's lots of other ways that people
are abusing these things all right
so let's move forward here all right so
if we're not going to be passing an
async function to a callback if we are
not supposed to be mixing these things
how do we actually get by it right the
answer is if you're going to be using
promises go all in on promises if you're
going to be using callbacks just do
everything callbacks right if you're
going to be mixing them it's it actually
gets very complicated I'll show you an
example of kind of doing it right and
I'll show you how complicated it gets
this in this case we're fully we're
using promises throughout the entire
player so we're using the promise fight
version of the FS module right so we
have a promise I'd version of open that
we can await what this what this version
of open gives you is a file handle
object that will automatically close if
you forget to do it now it'll give you a
morning but it will it will go ahead and
clean up after itself if you forget to
do it
try to avoid that memory leak but it'll
get you know it'll be noisy when it does
it it'll say hey you should be
explicitly closing this thing do that
next time alright so this is a much
safer way of doing this error handling
is consistent throughout and we're
properly propagating errors in context
here alright so just as a general rule
do not mix callbacks promises do one or
the other
alright now it is possible I guess it
took a bind them becomes much more
complicated alright so in this
particular case I'm creating the promise
I have the resolve reject I have two
callbacks two nested callbacks that are
happening right I'm having to propagate
the reject through those different
levels so this is you know if you've
heard a callback he'll this is you know
call back in promise hell and it just
gets even nastier right and the problem
the reason this is nasty is that
promises and callbacks operate on two
completely different abstraction models
right yes both involves scheduling async
activity but how they are resolved how
they you know in the execution model or
are entirely different and incompatible
to one another so you have to kind of
bunch them together in order to get them
to work now utilities like util dot
promise if I which will take a callback
function and wrap it it does quite a bit
of work under the under the covers to
make sure this is done correctly alright
so make use of util promise file I have
a few examples of that in here this like
you can do if you want a promise fide
version of set timeout and you can do
let's say sleep equals util promise if I
set timeout right and then from there
and like you know sleep actually becomes
promise fide right you can do whatever
right
okay and that actually you know it won't
block the event loop it's just the timer
that's happening under the covers but
it's been wrapped in a way that that
does proper propagation of errors all
right
event emitter this was mentioned in
giuseppe's talk earlier if you want to
create an event you mater that
understands proper error handling with
with async functions you can do let's
see if you pass in the capture
rejections
now this isn't in a in a node release
yet so it's not gonna work with the
version of node I'm using here for the
musing release version but so this will
error fight you know it won't work
properly if I run example but what this
will do is if you pass the basic
function again if it errors it will
cause a error event to be emitted
properly right it won't be hidden by the
DePalma string okay so there are ways to
do this correctly it's just complicated
and difficult and you know Matteo
cleaning his talk yesterday made the
point that you might spend a ton of time
in your code doing it correctly but I
can guarantee you there's somebody on
your team or another team the arrogant
that will just do it wrong right so it's
very difficult to do this consistently
and we have seen this time and time and
time again where especially with people
not handling errors correctly that it
just falls down okay so alright so let's
move on let's see here's the venue
matter alright so in order to do it
correctly without potatoes fixed by the
way if you're on a version of node
that's not it doesn't have the CAPTCHA
rejections yet you can do it but what
you have to do is within a try caption
your icing function you catch catch the
error and then you have to make sure you
admit that in a process next tick
alright the reason we have to do that in
a process next tick is because MIT is
asynchronous function when it is
operating when you call it in this
context from
than an async function if error handling
is bound to that promise right so if you
throw it's just going to be same part of
the same cop throw all right and you'll
end up with a an unhandled rejection so
next chick allows you to escape that all
right
it allows you to escape the promise
right so if you want to you know if
you're within that and you actually
absolutely want to get out of the
promise error-handling
you can always use next stick to do so
it's ugly it's nasty but it works all
right okay let's move on a little bit
more here okay so the other this one's
fun how many of you have seen long then
chains in your code right denne denne
denne dot then the worst one of these
that I've seen was about 15 or 16 of
these chained you know it's in a module
that's you know actually pretty
popularly used we recommend now if we
see it just don't just don't go use it
and what we typically find when people
have these long been chains is that
they're being used for basically make
the code readable and they're typically
end up being used for flow control of
synchronous code so in this particular
case we see no this is this one's pretty
contrived but it's you know again see
this all the time yeah we have two upper
to lower reverse we're basically just
isolating functionality into individual
functions and then we're going to chain
them together you know with with dense
this is absolutely pointless all of this
code is resolved synchronously right
it's all going to be executed
synchronously it's all going to be
blocking the event loop in one turn
right these promises are going to get
resolved in a the microbe task queue
that's the best part of all this that
excuse to the den and catch handlers
will actually be executed synchronously
immediately following the efficient you
know the resolution these promises
there is no asynchronous activity
happening here at all all you're doing
is taking a block of code that executes
right now in the event loop
and weaving it okay right here in the
vent loop but with a whole bunch of
allocate promise allocations on top of
it right do not do this
don't ever wrap use a promise to wrap
purely synchronous code this is probably
cardinal sin number one with with
promises all right but we see this all
of the time and every single time it's
because it makes it more readable right
it might make it more readable but it's
going to absolutely kill your
performance we've seen this code like
this we've seen it take code down maybe
60 70 percent performance toys just
because they're doing this kind of stuff
all right to make it even worse people
will do things like make these async
functions right which just causes even
more out promise allocations when you
await an async function do you know how
many promises are created just by cut
you know if it's just a empty async
function that does nothing else if you
await that function it creates three
promises every time no matter what else
it's do it all right
every time you await an async function
all right so you need to be aware of
what you're actually allocating here and
in and for what purpose you're actually
allocating those four all right so for
this you know it's it's simple if you if
you absolutely need that getdata to
return a promise right go ahead and
resolve the promise synchronously right
and use promise that resolved that's
what it's there for
that's the intent run your code
synchronously and save yourself the
trouble of all those additional promise
allocations all right there is no other
there's no other correct way of doing
this right do not rap sing clearly
synchronous code and a promise in a
promise chain of dense the only place
you should have purely synchronous code
is in the final then handler that is the
only place all right
all right let's keep going
loops oh these are fun passing an async
function to a functional loop like for
each or map or filter all right the
example I told you at the beginning
where the people were creating 30,000
promises this is how they were doing it
they were parsing a 1 Meg JSON file
iterating synchronously over every field
in that file creating a promise for
every field not just a promise a promise
change for every field right and
majority of those promise chains for
resolved synchronously so json.parse is
synchronous code iterating through the
synchronous loop allocating thousands of
promises in a you know synchronously and
then resolving them all synchronously
now let's see if you know why this is a
bad thing let me show you so we're gonna
go ahead and run no to get here run note
again with our trace events and then
this one is
all right so we're gonna let this run
for a bit and all this code is doing
taking you know setting a series of
numbers and then inverting the values
right we've got about a thousand of them
in there all right so it's gonna create
that trace event file again so how many
promises do you think were created
during that bring that operation let's
see no let's see why didn't that go all
right hold on a sec yeah make sure my
all right so how many are created during
that during that loop why isn't this not
coming up with all the information
I think I'm specifying something wrong
here oh no no okay so that how many
promises do we think we said like you
know five actually there's about 8,000
and we can see that here every single
one of these lines is a promise several
promises so these are all being created
in a synchronous loop right we really
the the iteration was a thousand
iterations right so we have about eight
thousand promises that were created over
that synchronous iteration now how do we
know it was all synchronous let's go all
the way down here at the bottom and we
see this v8 execute block right so this
is a synchronous code if we go back to
the trace event log every single one of
those promises was allocated
synchronously within the exact same
block right now in these particular
promises we do have a timer right so it
is they are scheduling a synchronous
activity but we're still allocating all
those promises all at once and there's
code running in those synchronous code
running in each of those that is causing
this massive event loop block so during
this time that event loop can't do
anything else
right we have one example of a customer
they were received their system was
receiving a whopping four requests per
second all right what was it doing
they were parsing very complex graph QL
queries that on the back end we're
talking about 10 or 15 back-end services
right the way the graph QL
implementation in Apollo works it's very
promise heavy uses these long promise
chains it goes off and parses the query
walks the query figure you know figures
out an execution plan for the query
right and then kind of goes through and
and executes the back end queries and
then reassembles the data right
well they receiving a large number of
timeout errors as they were there is
they're winning this thing and that's
actually why it what was killing their
their their throughput what was
happening is the backend services
services were receiving their queries
and they were returning data back all
right now the way that the event event
loop works when there's data that's been
returned it sits in a queue until the
event loop turns and it can say hey
there's data available I'm gonna go
ahead and fire off the callbacks
associated with those right but timeout
timers fire first so okay so the event
loop was being blocked long enough it
was sending the request the backend
servers were returning the data but by
the time the event loop turned over it's
a took too long so even though the data
is sitting there the the system would
crash and they were only getting four
requests per second through and their
solution to that was to throw a thousand
more servers at it I mean okay that
works I guess but whenever you're
creating promises in a synchronous loop
just don't or keep your iterations very
very small right there's an old rule you
know don't create a closure right limit
the number of allocations are doing in a
loop same thing here
every time you create a promise right
you're allocating something on the heap
alright so we just created 8,000 objects
on the heat right and a synchronous if
it's just not something you want to do
you have to be aware what's happening
when you're creating these promises
alright so another interesting this this
one just qualifies under I I don't have
any idea what they're doing or why right
return away new problem
a sink resolved pretty so first awake
this is this was based on a real
customer example we got like two weeks
ago right now what they're doing here is
assembling an object over time right and
these weights are actually going off in
doing database queries right and what
they want to do is if one of them dies
they don't want to continue right so
then art they don't want to go up and
execute all these things in parallel
they do want to do them one at a time so
they figured let's spread it out this
way where they came up with this return
away new promise they saying I have no
idea there should be a lint rule against
this and it should just reach out and
slap you every time you do it all right
so what's the correct way of doing this
on this there's a couple of ways let's
take a look at wand like uh uh well
that's that's um we're doing it in
parallel all right okay so if we really
wanted to wait on it right and do these
things you know the way that they said
we just you know do this right it's much
more readable it actually makes sense
you're not using strange you know syntax
that you know should get you slapped and
it just works now in this case you're
still waiting to 600 milliseconds for
everything to complete right you're
still waiting for a one to finish first
and if it fails then you'll stop right
if you wanted to do it if you really did
want to do it in parallel then you could
use promise all and goes off and execute
these things all right quick comment on
promo song that I'm coming up to you
know you know running out of time here
promise all waits for you know
everything to to finish right behind uh
it'll short circuit at the first
rejection right what happens to the
other promises if one of those rejects
what happens to the other promises they
continue a lot of folks don't know that
all right
especially bad when they use when you
use promise race right promise race is
the first one you know the one that
finishes first is the winner what
happens if the other one is taking a
very long time to finish it still goes
and still blocks your event loop right
so you're using promise race actually
doesn't actually buy you very much
there are use cases for it in the
browser a node is just gonna kill your
performance all right so let me see yeah
that's that's essentially it I can go
back here to the slides we have some
basic rules to follow know when your
code is being executed right use trace
events if you use the - trace event
categories you know and turn on the v8
category you will see exactly when
javascript is running right you will
know when it's you'll know when it's not
running all right
you want to make sure that you if you
are you making use of promises that you
are spanning those barriers your you
know your promises should not be
resolving within the same event you know
this the the same v8 execution right if
they are go back and figure out what's
wrong or don't use a promise there all
right
don't use unexpected promises just don't
write if a function does not if you do
not know that it is designed to take an
async function do not pass an async
function you know again
avoid mixing promises and callbacks use
one or the other all right
don't create promises and loops again
synchronous promises are just useless
and do not use long Ben chains just
avoid it as much as you possibly can
all right so that's it thank you
you